so what is the most powerful adaptogen
well what is an adaptogen an adaptogen
is something that helps you cope with
stress it helps you stabilize something
called homeostasis so it's your body's
adjusting to the environment so if you
stood up really fast right and you get
dizzy that's not adjusting to your
environment your body should be able to
quickly
shift your blood pressure and shift the
blood up into your brain so you don't
pass out or let's say you run up the
stairs right your body should adapt to
that and you shouldn't go unconscious so
if there's a problem in your ability to
adapt to stress
then an adaptogen can help you but most
adaptogens focus on increasing your
resistance
to
stress
and the most powerful adaptogen that i
know is ashwagandha ashwagandha does a
lot but in this video we're going to
primarily focus on
how it can help someone with stress it's
been around for a couple years like 3
000 years many different cultures
have used ashwagandha for
all sorts of things
but primarily most people use it to cope
with stress the main chemical compound
in ashwagandha that is responsible for
this stress adaptation
is with analytes and with analytes is
kind of like a a category of 300
different similar compounds so what
happens when you take ashwagandha
is you start
feeling
calm you feel like you can cope better
and i'm going to talk about why number
one it helps to modulate or control
something called the hpa
axis this communication between the
hypothalamus pituitary and your adrenals
okay so
let's say you experience stress right so
stress is received by the body
and the hypothalamus is like the owner
of the football team that sends the
message to the coach which then sends
the message to the quarterback to give
the play out to get everyone on the same
page
so in other words these hormonal
communications
are all about
getting the body ready or adapting to a
stress response and then once the
hormone does its job adapting the body
to stress
then a signal is sent back turning off
this mechanism and this is the problem
with chronic stress that message never
comes back to turn things off and so we
have this chronic elevation
of
cortisol
now what's really cool about ashwagandha
is it can help to turn off cortisol and
another hormone called dhea now when i
talk about turn off i'm not talking
about completely i'm talking about
reducing it to a certain amount and so
ashwagandha in various studies i think
there's like roughly about 41 different
studies just on
stress alone but there's a lot of other
studies on a lot of different aspects of
what it can do
but in this one study which i'm going to
put down below it can help reduce
cortisol and dhea
now the thing about cortisol cortisol
does not
cause you to be stressed out sometimes
people say boy my cortisol is too high
it's stressing me out or my adrenals are
overactive and stressing me out no
it's the stress that's causing the
adrenals to
pump out more cortisol cortisol is there
just to adapt your body to stress it's
doing its job and the problem is if
you're under sustained stress it's just
not very healthy to have your body in
this state so let's just take a peek at
what cortisol
does okay this is just some of the
things that it will do
number one i already mentioned this um
it responds to stress
it doesn't cause stress it's just
adapting your body to a stress state so
the first thing it's going to do it's
going to increase your blood sugars okay
this is called the flight or fight mode
it's a stress mode like if there is a
lion chasing you
you can either fight them or run away
so it's quick energy it's increase or
mobilize your blood sugars the problem
with chronic stress is that sugar then
will trigger insulin
and convert to belly fat and a lot of
other problems like high triglycerides
high cholesterol and also it can burn
out the pancreas and even cause diabetes
if there's
enough of this cortisol being pumped out
the other thing that cortisol will do
it'll turn off certain
things in our body that are not
necessarily related to
this present time threat okay
so it temporarily turns off your immune
system so it just shuts the thing down
this is why
people take prednisone for example which
is a synthetic cortisol
for anything inflammation autoimmune
diseases
allergies
poison ivy
skin problems
lung infections etc etc so the immune
system is temporarily put on pause okay
the other thing that cortisol will do
is it decreases the sensitivity to
insulin now this is not a good thing we
want insulin very very sensitive so it
can regulate your blood sugars so if it
makes insulin
less sensitive it actually creates
insulin resistance what your body's
trying to do it's trying to prevent
tissues from using glucose so it's
trying to conserve and use that
glucose for energy now it also will
increase sodium and water retention this
is why when people are stressed they're
just like a fluid-filled
sac especially in their ankles
at the same time it increases potassium
excretion
so your body is getting rid of potassium
and retaining
sodium this is why
when you're under stress for a period of
time
you become even more potassium depleted
and you hold on more sodium so this is
just another reason why potassium is so
important during a stress state so but
what do people do when they're stressed
they eat salty crunchy carbs right like
potato chips or other chips things like
that what are they doing you're
increasing more blood sugar and more
salt retention when cortisol goes up we
also get a spike in gastric acid
so you may find that your stomach has
like acid reflux or just heartburn and
if stress goes on long enough
that can irritate and create
inflammation in your stomach and that's
called gastritis
this is one of the reasons why stress
can actually create an ulcer and
actually damage in your stomach but not
just in your stomach it can also damage
the brain
so chronic stress can actually cause
some major damage to your hippocampus so
then you start losing memory and the
ability to learn and your cognitive
function
all right let's go back to this
right here
so ashwagandha
can
lower
cortisol to a certain degree as well as
dhea what is dhea it's kind of a
precursor
for cortisol and other hormones so this
is elevated during stress and guess what
ashwagandha actually can help lower this
which is a good indication
that your body is less stressed if you
have a lesser amount of dhea
that's still within the normal range and
you have a lesser amount of cortisol so
based on this study which is a
double-blinded placebo test
they found
lower am cortisol so lower cortisol in
the morning there is also lower dhea in
the morning there is a slight increase
in testosterone because
stress does shut down testosterone so
the fact that it raised was is a good
thing also ashwagandha increased
endurance okay so you can go longer when
you exercise it increases strength okay
because one of the things that
stress does is it makes you weak and
ashwagandha is really good for someone
that feels weak after stress
like let's say for example you had some
immune infection and you're trying to
recover from that because when you feel
really weak ashwagandha is a really good
thing to increase the strength or let's
say you've been under a lot of stress
for many days and you're not sleeping
that well ashwagandha can help raise
your strength so you at least don't feel
weak and ashwagandha showed significant
improvements in emotions so ashwagandha
has a tendency to bring you up so you're
not stuck in this stress state now if
you wanted a really good ashwagandha
product i did put a link down below in
the description check it out now since
we're on the topic of stress you have to
see
this video on stress it is very very
important i put it up right here check
it out